food insecurity was a real problem in
different families this is something
that I had to go through growing up and
so I didn't want anyone to ever have to
spend a night hungry and not have food
this great big story is by Singapore
Airlines
my name is city no Mistura and I am the
founder of back to basics back to basics
is a nonprofit organization and what we
do is that monthly we serve families
with groceries food insecurity was an
issue for a family who it became a
struggle hunger is something so or food
and you don't think about this until
you're in that situation you don't think
you will end up in that situation so in
2013 like she started volunteering with
different organizations with my best
friend and so that's when I start
talking to her and saying you know what
we should do something about the food
insecurity in Singapore so the first
groceries that we bought were basically
with our own money and we do the word it
two three houses and then it just you
into more families and that's what we
did for the next six years the next
drive that's happening it's 31 families
we have those who are elderly we have
big families we have single parents so
it's rice oil broccoli onions carrots
potatoes bananas our idea is that if
you're not spending money buying these
basic things that money can be rolled
out into something else that you need I
don't think that poverty will end in my
lifetime but I think the point is
annoying that it's not about solving
everyone's issue it's really about
making a difference even in just one
person's life and in order to just solve
one person's problem it really just
takes one person and that person can be
used
[Music]
you
[Music]